wir haben ja jetzt die debatte in
deutschland angezettelt auch von anteil
der politik dass wir eine allgemeine
impfpflicht brauchen das ist nicht nur
ein wortbruch sondern das ist vor allem
eine debatte die meines erachtens nur
dazu dient von dem versagen der
politiker der letzten regierung aber
auch schon der aktuellen teilweise ist
es ja auch identisch was die spd angeht
von diesem versagen abzulenken dass sie
nicht die dinge tun die jetzt wirklich
notwendig wären um die pandemie und
corona einzudämmen dass sie zum beispiel
noch nicht mal in der lage sind jedem
der sich impfen lassen möchte oder der
eine auffrischungsimpfung möchten diese
auch zeitnah zur verfügung zu stellen
nein das ist ja jetzt schon ein problem
in vielen bundesländern man wartet lange
auf impftermine es wurde viel zu sehr
verschleppt die musterung in den
pflegeheimen inzwischen ist sie wohl
weitgehend abgeschlossen es wären aber
todesfälle vermeidbar gewesen
ja und jetzt diskutiert man über eine
allgemeine impfpflicht unter lauter aber
offenbar im nächsten jahr wird
wahrscheinlich gar nicht genug impfstoff
da sein und ich finde das zeigt doch
wirklich man soll sich doch mit dem
dingen beschäftigen die man wirklich tun
kann und da wäre sehr viel mehr möglich
die impfpflicht die führt uns letztlich
nicht aus der pandemie junge leute die
ohne vorerkrankungen liegen überwiegend
nicht auf den intensivstationen der
akuten notstand dort hat andere ursachen
zb auch im gesundheitswesen da würde ich
mir wünschen dass da endlich mehr getan
wird gegen pflegenotstand und ein
argument ist leider auch mit delta schon
nicht mehr relevant und erst recht nicht
mehr wenn omikron sich ausbreitet die
impfung schützt leider nicht davor dass
man sich ansteckt dass man das virus
weiter gibt wenn das so wäre wie bei
masern oder früher bei der pockenimpfung
dann hätte ich finde ich auch gäbe es
gründe über eine impfpflicht
nachzudenken weil dann würde man damit
tatsächlich das virus ausbremsen das ist
bei corona bei den aktuellen impfstoffen
nicht der fall und deswegen finde ich es
muss eine persönliche entscheidung
bleiben ob man sich impfen lässt oder
nicht kroner ist eine gefährliche
krankheit vor allem für bestimmte
risikogruppen man sollte dafür werben
aber man sollte auch allen menschen die
möglichkeit geben die die aktuellen
neuen impfstoffe die da skeptisch sind
traditionelle impfstoffe zu bekommen und
vor allem sollte die politik jetzt
wirklich dass du was aktuell nötig ist
nämlich da impfstoffe zur verfügung
stellen wo menschen sich impfen lassen
möchten und selbst das ist ja nach wie
vor nicht gewährleistet
ich muss aufpassen weil ich habe diese
fehlerfrei paar tage auf twitter gemacht
und die reaktion war nicht schön ich
muss sagen ich habe
viel darüber nachgedacht ich bin kein
experte in diesem bereich da sind sie
und viele andere viel fitter in diese
situation aber ich sage in dem moment wo
impfpflicht die lage
verbessern konnte bin ich da vor und ich
bin dafür dass wir darüber nachdenken
und ich finde es ist viel einfacher zu
sagen impfen schützt nicht wir haben
millionen von menschen die sich nicht
geimpft haben wenn wir wie erreichen und
wenn das ein impfpflicht wäre wo sie
sich impfen lassen werden dann sind wie
in eine ganz andere situation
und ich frage mich ob das ein wortbruch
war was die politik betrieben hat oder
vielleicht eine umdenken dann die
situation ändert sich mann hat am anfang
gehofft dass viele menschen sich
freiwillig impfen jetzt haben wir eine
andere situation
ich habe eine sechsjährige tochter ich
will nicht mehr über schulschließung
sprechen ich bin normal leben ich will
urlaub machen ich will meine normalität
wieder haben und ich sage wieder da bin
ich nicht der experte aber wenn im
pflicht uns diese situation er bringt
dann bin ich da vor und wir sollten
darüber reden das bedeutet aber nicht
dass meine meinung heiliger ist alles
ihre sondern wir müssen eine offene
debatte darüber führen wir müssen
argumente austauschen wir müssen auch
die gegner von endlich zu lassen dass
sie auch ihre meinung sagen aber diese
debatte will ich einfach ich sage mal
ideologiefrei fühlen und ich bin nicht
attackiert werden ich will nicht dass
man mir wunsch dass meine kinder sterben
weil ich vor impfpflicht bin diese
debatte muss man hier verlassen wir uns
glaube ich alle einig also was du da
twitter kassierte es war einfach unter
aller kanone und das zeigt auf wie so
manche los du wurdest angeprangert deine
kinder sollten einem impfstoff sterben
gerade award leider muss man wirklich
kein finger breit diesen haase gern
welche du hast gerade gesagt du willst
diese debatte ohne ideologie führen ich
finde ich bin ja gegen die impfpflicht
ich bin ja diese immer licht gegnerin ja
und ich sage jedesmal wir wollen sie
ohne ideologie führen ich finde die ins
für worte machen ganz viel emotion und
ideologie rein weil ich will dass meine
kinder zur schule gehen das verstehe ich
finde es grausam dass kinder nicht zur
schule gehen konnten auch mit blick auf
die soziale gerechtigkeit in diesem land
aber da ist natürlich immer die frage
hätten kinder hier aus der schule raus
genommen werden müssen zweiter punkt
warum also ich finde die impfpflicht hat
nichts damit zu tun habe kinder zur
schule gehen können oder nicht also das
ist für mich das wird immer so vermischt
in der debatte und damit wird diese
gesellschaft so gegeneinander aufgehetzt
finde ich weil natürlich damit da
gewichtet die andere nein meine these
ist in dem moment wo im pflicht uns eine
gewisse normalität an weiter allein raus
aus der pandemische lage raus aus dieser
infektionszahlen wenn das der fall wäre
dann bin ich für eine impfpflicht und
weil das ja natürlich hat das auch mit
schulschließungen alles anders
da sieht man es wieder wir müssen sehr
genau hinschauen was heißt denn ich war
immer gegen die impfpflicht gegen die
allgemeine impfpflicht das ist schon was
wo ich mir denke es müsste einige
überzeugen gehen warum hat das bei uns
eigentlich so schlecht geklappt im
vergleich zu portugal im vergleich zu
italien im vergleich zu spanien
die spanier die portugiesen die haben
genau gesehen was dieses virus anrichten
kann zumindest bei bestimmten
bevölkerungsgruppen für die war völlig
klar völlig ohne impfpflicht denn auch
ohne dass es ein general dazu brauchte
den gab es zwar aber das haben die
freiwillig gemacht haben gesehen
portugal haben sie gesehen was kann man
dagegen tun oder gibt es einen impfstoff
also haben sie gesagt er damit bitte
sofort hier impfen die haben im quote
liegt deutlich höher als unsere und die
haben gute ergebnisse damit erzielt das
finde ich auch sehr in ordnung die
kinder impfung ist wenn eine ganz andere
geschichte und wenn wir eine impfpflicht
haben und die sollte sich tatsächlich
dahingehend ausweiten dass sie auch die
fünf- bis elfjährigen ich nehme es mal
diese gruppe weil die ja jetzt gerade
daneben ansteht und die sollte die noch
mit berücksichtigen dann sage ich da ist
eine grenze überschritten
da bin ich auch nicht davor also ich
das haben wir einfach klasse die noch
nicht ganz wichtig dass unterscheiden
denn was sie gesagt haben auch dass sie
uns auch sie wieder wir wollen wieder
dann am leben teilnehmen das ist ja eine
bürokratische indikation als ärzte reden
wir ja von einer medizinischen
indikation und die muss mit ja
beantwortet werden können und das könnte
ich für ein 5 bis 11 jähriges gesundes
dass der entscheidende unterschied
gesundes kind nicht so ohne weiteres
sagen ich glaube nicht dass die impfung
letzter satz sehr gefährlich ist aber
ich frage mich bringt das dem kind maß
und bringt das in der epidemie böblingen
auch bleiben wir beim spanien spiel hat
er auch logistisch unfassbar viel anders
getan als
den punkt er auf in die diskussion noch
einbringen ich finde dass das thema auch
von den politikern viel zu ideologisch
und viel zum pädagogisch und alles
mögliche diskutiert wird ich mache mal
steil ich sie zu 99 prozent so der staat
ist in erster linie logistikunternehmen
und so hat er auch seinen job
auszuführen und wenn es eine große
pandemie gibt und wenn man die impfung
als ein mittel dagegen erkannt hat dann
muss der staat alle mittel die er hat
ausschöpfen damit die menschen sich
animiert fühlen sich impfen zu lassen
hatte aber nicht es gibt keine
milliardenschwere werbekampagne es gab
keine werbe spots vor der tagesschau das
hat ja sogar die telekom hin gebracht
als sie ihre aktion seinerzeit wir waren
wohl gab es nicht es gibt keine
anschreiben an jeden einzelnen bürger
schon gar keine telefonaktionen es gibt
zu wenig streetworker die in
problemvierteln darauf aufmerksam an es
gab noch nicht mal eine prämie 50 euro
für jeden der es tut all das jeder
einzelne kann man kritisch sehen ich
sage nur erst wenn all das ausgeschöpft
ist wenn all das versucht worden ist und
wenn dann die impfquote immer noch nicht
bei über 90 prozent liegt erst dann ist
es überhaupt statthaft über einen
eingriff in die freiheit nachzudenken
wie den menschen eine pflichtaufgabe und
das ist das was mich dabei erzählt dass
eine nicht zu tun die logistik als top
flop zu machen das neueste eigenes von
heute ist ja wieder also ich meine
kriegen kann man jetzt wieder zu wenig
impfstoff haben diese vollkommen absurd
aber wieder der logistiker dann kriegen
wir wieder nicht verteilt warum hat
nicht irgendjemand mal gesagt wir
schließen amazon die deutsche post und
unsere hermes zusammen und wir machen
den großen auslieferungsplan 1 der staat
hat als logistiker versagt und jetzt
sollten sich alle leute pflicht eine
spritze geben lassen das finde ich
wirklich problematisch